I didn't watch porn I thought that if
you did porn he had do everything I
didn't know you could like pick and
choose what scenes you want to do you
can just bang girls and get paid I
didn't even notice that it was being
filmed I was just really excited to like
[__] you just not give us you know some
of my family doesn't agree with what I
do some of our friends you know but I
don't care you're not okay with it
that's fine but I'm not gonna change who
I am it's a very incestual industry
everyone's worked with everyone everyone
who [__] everyone I go to set and I
[__] a girl and then I have a drink with
her and her husband and then I [__] her
husband the next day as long as it is
two consenting adults in a safe
environment
what about porn is so much it's just
miserable constant power we are in
control we make more money than men
we're living our best life getting the
best dick like how is this something
that you can know right there was like
this phase of parodies and they were
just all so bad butts so fun you do the
matrix I would like to be Neil and then
I call and then it's coming towards
efficiency avoids it yeah that you stops
the chocolate yeah and they're just one
drop the touches are on the tip she's
like you would say oh I had a great
podcast today and we would say oh how
was your anal scene oh it was great
oh my god he got all 12 inches in I got
Piledriver he was just plowing it and it
was gray camel over my face like that's
a regular conversation
I like being choked and [__] slapped
across the face right I [__] love it
but it's someone that doesn't know me
could be watching my porn flick oh my
god for her I'm like I'm kind of curious
about how long did in a day you would
spend being a cowgirl um I would have a
goal amount of money that I would want
to make and then when I hit that goal
I'd be done like uber yes yeah it was
like uber for my [__] yeah
[Music]
we warmed them up yeah welcome to the
podcast our lives are yours
hey one of my favorite porn stars of all
time I mean your top three easy okay
don't ever tell a person that it's not a
good way to start is a bad way not the
best but your top three yeah I mean a
porno because it's like a big shop in it
there's so much so you very rarely
settle on one like the whole time we've
booked some massive guessing I don't
know we've had huge people on like you
know do you know who Robbie Williams is
yeah do you know who Ricky - miracles a
massive though I mean I've seen Brian go
got Robbie Williams on got Ricky Gervais
is the other day when got Danny Daniels
on and then the rest day is literally
going all day all day this I can write
you know you make that face weirdly
because you're getting excited over
having money heroes on I can imagine you
as a baby so that's quite something
isn't it I feel like you came out as a
baby with a beard yeah I was always big
covered in that like you know cream ease
you know we have a baby and it sort of
all just comes out like in that I'm more
nervous than usual it's not coming
across definitely I'm sorry
yeah probably ought to change the grade
in post just for the redness you you you
are not you're are you you're a calm
girl no is that right would you call
yourself that you do like a commis order
I do I do have you been in my rooms what
are you doing when I know I want to know
what the product cam so dick all right
so can you explain that for someone who
doesn't know cam so does a campsite I
know what I can say is oh it's
it's a cam company that company and so I
am contracted with them to only cam with
them so I only do my website which is
Danny Daniels comm shameless plug and I
do my premium snapchat daily Bush calm
which he likes the bush yeah yeah and
then I do Kim right okay yeah I wouldn't
consider myself a cam girl though
no you you've definitely beyond that I
started doing cam and stripping and then
I did porn and then I doing cam again so
it's kind of so if you taken because
obviously you're married now your
husband's actually in the room yeah
actually yeah
is that what you're so nervous no
definitely not it's just because of you
know no offense so are you now not doing
porn now that you're married um I only
do it for my sites it just
coincidentally I got married shortly
thereafter I didn't really make an
announcement when I stopped shooting for
other companies because I just
it wasn't really my style so once people
started to notice that I was no longer
shooting they also noticed that I was
getting married but it was like a
two-year delay so so you do still do
some shoots like that yeah just for my
sight oh yeah yeah I think self
unselfish I know this is a weird
question do you fund most yourself mate
they're like a another party that goes
we're interested in doing this no I have
my own production company because let's
be honest you got like performer of the
air and stuff like you're not you went
to the very top the best sucker came and
took my trophy you're gonna do something
you want to be number one yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a football award though yeah
it's for a huge school thing anyway so
you got to a point where now you're your
own business like you know you've you've
made it in that way like what was the
experience like how did you even get in
a pond for a start like how does someone
because obviously like everyone likes
sex but not many people go good getting
paid for this
was kind of an accident I was I went to
art school and I was stripping to pay
off my school debt and I would I told
the stories on my time so I'm sure
someone's heard this that's watching but
I we've got we've got Marvel yeah I was
dancing one night and I heard someone
say talk about a girl girl porn star and
I have always seen myself as bisexual so
I didn't know I thought I didn't watch
porn I thought that if you did porn eheh
do everything I didn't know you could
like pick and choose what seems you want
to do so I was like you can just bang
girls and get paid to bang girls and
they're tested and it's safe yeah yeah
sign me up I'll do that
so it just kind of of her delusions a
lot of people are doing that even more
so now like is in like they're at uni a
college or ever and they're doing like
sex work you know what appear stuff off
now obviously there's different lien
stripping book yeah it's it's becoming
really common though yeah I mean the
stripping was to pay off school but um I
have to be saw this porn was selfish I
just wanted a pink row
alright I was just happy I was getting a
check at the end so but yeah I think I
think a lot more it's more accepted than
you know if you're stripping on the side
or it camming on the side it's like oh
yes coming this because like so normal
yeah isn't it yeah I'll be the normal of
it yeah no it is alright pop it really a
lot of people doing any more more yeah
because I feel like if it was very
popular right no one I don't know any
well we've had one on the podcast we -
now so I don't know do you know what I
mean though so it's not like everyone is
I mean I'm not making out like every
single woman is doing pokemon cards you
know me yeah I'm just to be clear
oh yeah all women are doing it yeah no
it's more it's more common at least I
think compared to maybe 10 years ago I'm
kind of curious like how long did in a
day you would spend being a kanga how
long you spend doing it per day oh I
think it depends on the person so what
about you hello me um I would have a
goal amount of money that I would want
to make and then when I hit that goal
I'd be done like uber yeah yeah it was
like uber for my [__] yeah right I'm
telling the merit
oh thank me later it is like uber
because I know it
drivers may you chat to them breaks in
the chat really yeah one of them did
actually say is like it with you and
they just go yeah I make certain that
money and then I just [__] off yeah yeah
and I guess you can encourage times it's
an hour sometimes it's eight sometimes
you don't hit your goal just so how do
you make more money is it you just do
more and more stuff I think building
your social media and your following and
doing a good job people you get
returning customers and you're an
entrepreneur like like in that way
you've found a way to use what you've
got to make what you want to make and
now you're like you're doing this Amazon
Prime sure like your cross and all that
like very few can't do actually was that
always the goal um no I I just I had
this really bad habit of working too
much and taking on too many projects
because I get bored easily
yeah and so I wanted to do a show that
kind of showed people that porn is a job
and we just we work a job and we're
regular people and we go home and
there's funny stories involved and so I
was that to dinner with one of my
girlfriends and we were swapping stories
and my husband was what like you know
you would say oh I had a great podcast
today and we would say oh how was your
anal scene oh it was great
oh my god he got all 12 inches in you
know you I got Piledriver he was just
plowing it and it was gray camel over my
face like that's a regular conversation
there's nothing it's normalized I've
watched a bit of the show definitely
that's normal yes
I wanted it's funny and fun and I want
to just to show the personality side you
know points are the main reason people
would not do poorly because there may be
men and women sitting there watching us
it sounds like fun but it's like the
judgment of the parents and things like
that that's what put you off like it
puts a lot of people have a lot of
things that worried of what people think
do you just not give a [__] when I know
I do not know um I didn't really plan
ahead like I was just so excited to [__]
women that like I was 21 like I just I
was yeah like I don't want to say it was
young and dumb I was just young and
excited and then when you get on on your
first shoot can you sort of talk us
through what you are feeling because
it's excitement but then at some point
were you a little bit nervous or worried
what was going through your head reality
I think there's a lot of people that
wanna get into porn because they want to
be porn stars I got into porn because I
wanted to explore my bisexuality so for
me I didn't even notice that it was
being filmed I was just really excited
to like [__] and it sounds like it's
supposed to be hot but like I just I was
just stoked to be there so once the
scene was over I would say maybe I had a
moment of like oh that's gonna be on the
Internet
but I didn't care what why'd you care
like what I just I don't want to live my
life based upon other people's opinions
of me I'm gonna do whatever I enjoy
whatever I love and if people don't want
to like it I don't care because I go to
sleep at night and I love my life
so and so but obviously in order to love
your life some people say there's like
requisites that you need and I'm not
talking like nail and you in any way
here is just sort of I'm curious yeah
good choice of words sorry networking
probably my yeah mine's never said to
another guest I'm trying to nail you
here so we decide that I'm so interested
in is like how you know that the family
side of it like did you think about mmm
yeah what's your relationship like your
parents like I have a great relationship
my parents are separated I was actually
raised by
two women and I have a good relationship
with my father you know my family I
didn't think about my I didn't have a
fear of my parents finding out because I
didn't think that far into the future
right
probably irresponsible in my part but
that's just the honest truth and when
they found out there was a moment of
they were afraid like for some reason my
mom thought I was gonna get into drugs I
think that's kind of stereotype of the
industry like all in robes and doing
blow off each other's [__] like but
it's not the case and so once she
realized that I was in it and I was safe
and it was a business and she saw that
where my head was at she was okay with
it I wouldn't say she was for it but she
supports me do you think your upbringing
sort of helped you to approach that yeah
yeah I like sex I grew up in a household
where sex wasn't not talked about right
do you mean is in obviously no sex
between parents were like you could ask
them I guess I could ask my mom anything
right and it was never I was never in
fear of talking to her about anything so
maybe that had something to do with it
well I grew up in Orange County
California yeah just checking oh yeah
okay sorry I live in New York now but
yeah in California okay and you spent
and then obviously you're in the porn
industry in California as well which is
where a sort of famous for being yeah
now it's a little more between Los
Angeles and Vegas but do you remember
what your first where your first shoot
wasn't what it was yeah it was for
everyone's gonna be like on Google as I
say this I would love to do the Google
tracking after this is [__] wrong
honestly my first girl girls for reality
kings it was actually three women in me
so four in total and it was yeah I mean
like the sex was a blur cuz I just
excited I was like who wants to know my
face like I'm happy to be here
oh this is great and then can you
remember how much you paid for love and
I saw would you rather not say I'd
rather not say
but I didn't I wasn't I did at the time
I didn't I don't even think I knew oh
that's cool this is an added bonus
right that's a 21 year old have sex with
three beautiful women and I had to do a
zero work to get there and it we're all
tested it's all safe like what what at
what point was it was it going to men
then from there was it long before you
were like our [__] let's try the
whole lot Wow so you do purely just yeah
that's a long time what tempted you
because three or four years that's a bit
of a trend and then I'd actually didn't
want to do boy-girl and then a lot of
mio talents are a little bit irritating
and I like to have a connection with my
partner and it's easier for me to
connect to women than men but why are
they ever taking out of interest ah can
you tell me some specific things that
have bothered you in your vagina via
that weird thought oh man I don't like
cocky men that much the ego sometimes
gets a little you know if a guy comes in
the room and things that I you know I
can [__] whoever I want
I'm not [__] you yeah alright just
out of spite right but I lucky I'm not
like that no no he was really nervous so
yeah when he greets do it well hello
[__] off yeah so no women like that in
the industry then so because women can
also have an ego and there's no good
it's easier for me just to tune that out
because it's it's an ass Wow
right alright so you lean more towards
women then yeah would you say it's
easier for me to have sex with a woman
and not have that mental connection yeah
than a man okay
like I can just I can appreciate a woman
just for being beautiful and her body
and just being happy to eat her [__]
with men I have to somewhat connect with
them I don't know why
because your husband is quite feminine
isn't he - look at just to explain he's
a model Iman I've ever seen okay that
makes exactly two repertory words that
say yeah yeah I don't know just my
personal me personally I need I needed
some sort of connection with my male
co-stars so I would be on sets and would
meet men I guess I could [__] that guy
hey I guess he was cool and then I
compiled a list which is actually I
don't think had ever been done in
foreign before you can have a no list
but no-one's ever had like a yes list so
I was like here's 10 dudes that I'd [__]
and that's all you can pick from you you
work with them over and over again yeah
and how did you know you you met them
around or meet him on set like like if
um if I was shooting there might be a
scene after mine like maybe I had a girl
girl see in there and there was a boy
girl scene after and there would be like
a male town onset and like a like I was
actually kind of cool yeah he's cute you
got a nice [__] it stayed hard that's
doable and add them to the list you know
maybe I mean another guy at like an
industry event or somewhere else and so
I just kind of compiled this wish list
of penis we've all done it this is so
when you're let's say yeah let's say
you're on set though because you know we
only see the bit way the movie starts or
whatever and it's all everything's
perfect and that and all the edits done
you know you said about a guy who can't
stay hard what kind of issues
have you seen there's ever been like we
just being like the guys weren't [__]
it's not gonna happen
yeah it happens yeah yeah I never with
me know it happens sometimes you know
you can have a bad day it's not you know
sometimes a guy will come to set and
he's just like just not I don't know
what it is it's just not a day so you
have to call the scene come back and
reshoot it or get a different guy in
yeah all sorts of stories about um they
inject in their dicks with stuff like is
that is that real does the [__] that
sounds really pain that really would
never occur like I don't care if I won
what the [__] going on I'm not gonna
needle immediately right what about you
no I'm just sort of wondering like where
the that made you almost like like
forbidden fruit in the industry people
are a bit like I want to be in want to
be on the list
sounds very egotistical but yes right
because it I don't know how to say it
everyone's it's very it's a very
incestual industry everyone's worked
with everyone everyone [__] everyone
you know like I go to set and I [__] a
girl and then I have a drink with her
and her husband and then I [__] her
husband the next day like it's not you
know there's not really another industry
like that is that weird though there's
not cause of it if cuz if you're friends
with a girl are you bit like I'd rather
not work with your husband because I'm
tired you can [__] my friendship yes I
have a husband sometimes for me
sometimes yeah it just yeah like there
was a girl in the industry I would work
with all the time and then when I
started doing boy-girl I knew her
husband from her and it was we I was
like I can't I can't work with him like
I was just too but also but then I have
friends that I have [__] both of them
and then I got to know them and then
that was fine so just every situation is
different talk about that list as well
there's some girls who like interracial
obviously a big thing important you held
off for a while some girls never do it I
held off because I don't like the term
innervation right okay um I understand
that it's necessary for searching like
milf yeah if you're looking for
something you have to you know you need
to cut agree but um I don't like a lot
of interracial porn because it's very
racial and I just just not something
that I'm into so I held off for a really
long time not because I didn't want like
I love Prince and I wanted to work with
Prince so bad but I was like I just
can't
he's dead go on your face I'm just
thinking that's all of her yeah
but he was bloody telling to this one
though he was credit really got no idea
how big is dick was we miss you probably
had already nonno's great pancakes but I
held off a really long time because I
just wasn't okay with the situation or
the senior um I and I waited until it
was something that I agreed with I
didn't want I didn't want to leave the
industry and be like god I wish I didn't
do that
so everything I've ever done I'm proud
of you you did blocked their ed it does
actually watch this podcast shadow of
their birthday what they probably would
have been in touch did you not know that
no they've message me you just said you
did black and they watch watch it's
blocked it's a pony like high level
they're the editors watch it I was
started that company credit to you Jeff
price is just an upside when I did that
movie it was fantastic because I could
write in my contracts like there won't
be nothing nothing racial no saying
interracial you know no thing I'm gonna
suck your big black dick like I just
it's not my thing I didn't want to do it
like that because you'll be on camera
and they'll want you to say it and then
you're like then you're in this weird
situation with a dick in your mouth like
I don't want to [__] say that right
where do I go from here it's like a
political talk all of a sudden when
you're supposed to be shooting so yeah
does anyone sort of dispute that is
there anyone who sorta goes [__] you
think you're too good for that like does
anyone there's gonna be opinions but I
don't [__] care then don't hire me
yeah cuz like I said like I don't do
anything I don't like I don't do
anything I don't agree with so and if
you have a problem with that no harm no
foul but I'm not the person for you
there's a line of girls that will suck a
dick that will do it
I won't so which makes sense it seems
you understand the power dynamic like
quite well which is something that well
women women are the bosses in that
industry it seems from the outside I
guess apparently men don't get paid as
good or whatever so ironic there's a
colony in feminist hate not all
feminists but a lot of feminists hate
porn I'm like I love porn because it
puts the woman in can we are in control
we make more money than men we're living
our best life getting the best dick like
how is this
something that you cannot hike yeah it's
not that might actually be the only
industry going where women are clearly
more paid than the men maybe maybe like
mainstream modeling maybe yeah I don't
know I'm not familiar with it but don't
either guess but yeah I mean I guess my
my reading of that would be that's
because some I mean I'll be honest I
don't really know enough about porn or
the industry in order to comment on it
but my reading of that from the outside
would be that it's because it sometimes
does reinforce stereotypes that men like
about women and then of course they can
evaluate the industry I think that a lot
of women look at not only women but I
think a lot of women look at porn and
they're like oh that poor girl
I like being choked and [__] slapped
across the face right I [__] love it
but it's someone that doesn't know me
could be watching my poor music oh my
god poor her I'm like that I was like oh
poor her it's like no it's like in this
situation that I enjoy I am controlling
the scene I am controlling the situation
I can say stop at any time yeah I choose
not to because I [__] love it my some
of my best scenes I'm crying it if you
look at that not very emotional yeah but
it's like the best have you ever cried
when you came it's awesome
right so what you're saying is no I'm
not comfortable I'm just trying to
actually chase this like down a hole is
like I'll show you up do you so then
you're saying then that you had you came
so well that you actually cried because
you were emotional about it yeah yeah
yeah in a scene in many scenes okay and
so is that something it's not unusual
odds are quite normal yeah yeah because
of a girl cries after sex on me like if
I went home with a guy and cried after
sex like it would freak him out mmm no
tell us
I don't know yeah I love it I love it
that's just my you know me personally I
love it and so I'd had I have worked for
scenes like kink they would have to stop
the scene and check in with me cuz
they'd be like are you crying because
you're enjoying this or do we need to
stop the scene right I had a girl cry
after sex one
but it was cuz some good you were on top
of each I'm a lot bigger than her like
but um she was arranged to be married
and she felt like guilty about it yeah
she was Iranian wonderful looking girl
oh yeah so you were [__] her before
she was getting married yeah like a
handy thing it was her last two rocks
was it wonderful thank you very much I
think you saying you like Harry but
that's fine so share the [__]
yeah yep see usually I don't know you
guys with beards like bushes is that a
thing do you think might we like the
match that's right twins likes a link
well I do I'd like well that was our
first started watching
Danny's videos was um English Rose
lookin girl like cuz I like the girl
next door of also in English English
Rose yeah like you look like the girl
next door
sort of thing like quite you don't want
like a pawn star I don't think you look
like a blonde bombshell porn star type I
mean so and uh I like bush as well then
I followed you on the snapchat I didn't
even care about stuff chap I was like
she's getting you do you have a snapchat
it was sucking all the Dee Williams plug
there you go then he sucking all the day
foam it now and you also did vine when
vine was a thing and I would just go on
like a lot of like my fan base it's
followed me the longest knows me because
I would show my bush every day like an
unflattering way and I'd be like it's my
Porsche and I were like seeing this
stupid Bush song I don't know what I was
thinking but I had time for the reason I
only had vine for that reason I remember
I wasn't fun when Logan Paul was one of
the only girls and everyone hated it and
everyone wanted me to shave it I get all
these hate comments why are you people
not like school Harry and I'm like [__]
you now all I'm gonna do is keep it the
entire time right just to be spiteful
what's wrong with Bosch though like why
is it not okay what I think it's lovely
if more common now but I do need Iraq I
feel like it's like people in like porn
like people didn't have Bush
it became unfashionable in their like
few thousands of something didn't it
like because when I was young we had two
porn magazines all the women had bushes
so in my head
Bush was the good thing that was what I
was looking forward to getting when I
was old enough you know but then all of
a sudden by the time I got there cuz I
think women look more feminine with a
bush like without getting to it's more
much like you're learning a lot about it
it's more woman coming rather than
nothing because that's a bit womanly I
like womanly bushes Lawrence tell me
some of them like let me some of the
weird things you've had to do in Palmer
you've been like I can't believe I'm
actually I can't believe I have a dick
in my mouth on the internet that's the
thing what he's not having - well no I
was yeah you've done like what you don't
do anal right no what is there is just
uncomfortable I don't like it in my
personal life I didn't I never did
anything on camera that I didn't enjoy
my personal life some girls it's an I
think that that's kind of mad have some
girls can take insane amounts of pot in
their ass and then other girls they can
take yeah like don't [__] come near
mass yeah but then to be honest I think
anal is overrated by the way because um
it's like you've got a perfectly good
hole that's designed but some women
enjoy anal sex more than just imagine
all sex yeah yes I'm with some women
love it and I think if you love it then
yeah do it on camera and enjoy yourself
but I just I don't enjoy it so why be
miserable on for everyone to see cuz if
I don't enjoy it when the lights are dim
why am I gonna enjoy it with a camera
three feet away
or three inches away would you say you
know because I've seen you do both well
you see you're more submissive or
dominant I am dominant with women and
submissive with men all right usually I
don't know I don't know
well I I don't really like women tell me
what to do I like to tell women what to
do a personal thing and with men I just
I like being submissive I like being
subservient yeah I think it's just
sexual preference do you think there's
like I'm not trying to get like Freudian
or anything but you think is like a
reason you like that
what do you mean like I say upbringing
but you think is like a personal
preference or reason or like do you want
to think about it in this deep level or
are you sort of like trying to remain
away from over analyzing it I if I was
to think about it for like five seconds
maybe because like I'm very masculine
right I like to smoke cigars drink
scotch play golf you're gonna love him
I'm like I just I dress feminine but I'm
I almost my friends are men I'm just a
you know like a masculine woman with a
bush so maybe and because I see women is
sexually I enjoy tits and ass I want to
touch them I want to pleasure them so
maybe maybe that's well I don't know
yeah that was again there's a common and
the porn industry for women to be a bit
more like I guess it England we'd say
like Malik lads like a bit tomboyish
type thing or are they all there really
because to me the concept of having sex
without being emotional is more
masculine than it is feminine because
there's definitely emotion really at
least for me have you seen people that
like did you ever be involved with any
of the guys like did you ever get
romantically involved
I was a serial male talent a term
industry it became like comical it's
easy it's easy to date in the industry I
didn't want to date outside the industry
because I go to work every day and
although we're all tested you are
putting your health
you know something could happen and I
didn't feel comfortable dating outside
of that bubble and especially as someone
that wasn't performing and then when
you're on set it's just easy because
you're working with a guy he understands
your job you know he's tested he gets
that you go to work every day and suck a
dick and that it's you know a job it
just makes dating easier the dynamic of
it I guess is chess so I tended to
always date no talents was that good or
a bad idea in retrospect how many so you
tasted quite do you get any very famous
porn stars yeah yeah I don't want to
like call them out or no yeah yeah I
mean yeah well did it ever did it ever
get like jealous there's a little bit of
jealousy so if you come home in on the
game with a guy who hating you and you
say was it like that oh yeah or like if
a guy you know like if I was dating a
guy and there was somebody that he was
insecure of because maybe he was a
better performer he was like I was it
was so so you know there or for me I
would be the same way you know if I if I
knew that my boyfriend was going to say
and working with a girl that he was into
I would suck the [__] out of his dick
when he came home just to show him who's
boss even if he was not good already
know my dominance I am peeing on your
leg come here territorial I would be
lying if I said I wasn't jealous at
certain times I think it's someone help
me because in that industry I don't know
you have to be sort comfortable with who
you are to get on camera and do and I do
respect that like especially the dudes
as well because they you know you've got
to be [__] delivered straight as soon
as they say in go yeah to then mentally
still get a bit insecure it but there's
also things that like people don't think
about like I don't know it's just the
relationships and then you're you know
could you imagine if your partner does
the same thing as you works in the same
office office building and then you all
[__] each other every day the drama on
top of drama you know the you know you
see so I don't want to work with
so I don't know you know Herick I have
to work with my friend's ex today is
that gonna be okay is that gonna make my
friend upset you know even though it's a
job it's like you're trying not to get
emotionally involved but it's so
difficult not to sometimes does it go
quite messy in what we relate
relationship-wise like you're so you're
you know you're ending up so you know if
your friend if I never said to you don't
go and do a scene with him because I
used to date him I can only speak for
myself yeah because I I don't I don't
everyone handles it differently there's
people that are married in the industry
that are very happy yeah there's people
you know in the industry that don't want
to date so it's just for me it could get
messy at times you know it's but it was
it was it was nice being with someone
that got it because a lot of guys you
date outside the industry don't
understand it so at least if you're
getting involved with a porn star though
you have to be so like selfish you are
cool a lot of guys think they can handle
it Oh BJ ting a porn star would be
awesome she loves to but then when I
leave to go to work every day can you
really handle it when I go suck a guy's
dick that's bigger than you can you
really handle it because the whole
industry is sort of built around
acknowledging that everyone has sexual
desires are a majority of people have
sexual desires a lot of people want to
act on those and so you're sort of
playing out a lot of fantasies the
denial side is almost the lack of
emotion that a lot of people who watch
porn attach to those things so you guys
naturally some people who are sex will
become emotionally attached mm-hmm so
it's I guess that's the dynamic in the
whole the whole industry like a denial
mm-hmm because we are acting yeah you
know I don't [__] over drivers you know
I'm not [__] the pizza guy but I am
and she's got standards but I am [__]
bastard another actor that is enough for
some people even though you know it's
like I am [__] someone but you know
it's not these story lions it is so
different than normal
normal like they're like I mean most
most men want to be lied to
when we say so how many guys you've been
within and what what's the biggest dick
you've ever heard though and like it
also it has to be do they go do I [__]
do you are
okay
I'm [__] more women than you have I
mean this guy's pretty prolific so I
mean I would I would expect to see
better than you as well I would agree I
would probably expect uh she is a woman
she's got the equipment so like no but
men yeah we'd like to I think men are so
insecure generally like naturally that
they want to feel like the biggest and
best and all the audience and and
literally the guy that you're now with
he's got video evidence that he knows
that he's not the biggest support
summaries you you're [__] good let's
no doubt about Fair Play
Oh emotionally you're attack those two
people are attached you found someone
that you love do you know I love him and
he's [__] great at giving me good
days I wouldn't have married them very
much part of the vows as well you phone
call from a Ferrari lifestyle to an uber
men what if I mean I'm not a man but I'm
assuming men want to feel like they're
the best
they you know they want a woman that's
like you're the biggest you're the
biggest I've only had one other [__] and
it wasn't as big as yours that's what
they would have [__] yeah just just to
be object he zoned everyone else out in
the room I could tell like who isn't you
know that scene in a John Travolta
you're very you're actually you whether
you are an actress like specifically in
like like how often did a in point often
do women have to fake cuz use him quite
like real you know I mean I usually
believe it when you're coming for and
I'm coming I never I'm not a faker some
girls fake it um I'm selfish I didn't I
didn't want to give my scene partner the
satisfaction of thinking they made me
come so
so so if they saw if they don't do you
do sometimes saying like you know like
if you watch my scenes like sometimes
I'm like humping someone's leg like I
will get off whether you like it or not
do you think I make you [__] I'm [__]
coming mm-hmm but you know you're
performing and I enjoy it I come and but
I know that I'm playing to an audience
so maybe instead of smothering a girl's
face with my [__] I'm turning it a
little bit towards camera but I'm still
enjoying myself and you get better at
sort of working out what looks good on
camera as you go yeah do you think
you're good or bad when you first
started I don't even think I was just
like in la-la land like I don't really
watch my scenes but if I see like a gift
or something on Twitter I'm like I was
enjoying that you could have left
I wouldn't even notice okay that's
interesting so you know we talked about
the cameras being in the room can you
like are you at a point now where you
can almost like direct yourself sort of
thing now I can when I first started I'd
get yelled at a lot
they'd be like Danny you need to open up
Danny you need to open up Danny open up
but like they would like I would get in
a lot of trouble because I'd be so into
it I'd like oh okay I have to hump this
way you know yeah Jenna was Donny
chuckle oh she's a time as in prime it
song as I Amazon yeah right I seen you
had alexis texas on there oh no no I
said I said top three home races
I can't choose to know why so kudos
different days like today's an Alexis
day it when it's your time of the month
do you like no I definitely know but the
thing is though like I think as a
younger man I mean you get like porn
girlfriend's who you just keep going but
you know that's a guarantee or this one
yeah do you have like a like a trail
like from 20 to 22 I like to this person
like ex-girlfriends yeah I think I saw
one of the first I remember was got one
called flower Toshi
oh yeah cuz she was like
just absolutely she was one of the first
yes she wasn't she wasn't as pretty as
some of the but she was just
unbelievable attainable she was a square
as well which is always fun to watch and
then sort of moved you move on dawnia
move up you just gonna break up with her
and move on I say on the sidebar ago we
had something special
yeah she's oblivious she's not in social
media this I can't even follow up you
can't even stalk her I can't even be
like nice you know like I fought as I
anything they're not there anymore
so again you're just looking for that
top three I to be honest with you it's
the two I've named you jealous that I've
[__] Alexis and you have it like but I
don't want to take that away from you
I'm glad that you had that diamond not
coming together convenient only woman
that has sat on my face and I
legitimately could not breathe and I had
like a moment of fear she has a huge
boat yeah for those I know her ass is
like just yeah it's Matt it since and
it's dense and [__] heavy mm-hmm
so she sat on my face and like Iram it
was like I I could not usually when you
get a girl's ass I don't know if you're
a nasty eater right you don't really
seem like the type but I think you might
surprise me he's a dog hostess
usually you can still kind of view
you're an ass eater for sure please you
can definitely get a little bit of air
circulation with her it was like I had
to hold my breath and she's the only
woman I've ever [__] I was like that
was insane it's a fun feeling though
it's a fun kind if I die if I go out yes
going out by being smothered by alexis
texas ass that's a death of a chump
definitely fine with that this is okay
this is a good way to die come here can
we get her onto some point I'll be
correct I'm sure she hasn't got her own
talk show no it's not really but you
you've got the person I like in order to
curry a chat show and that and you've
got there you got there Sophie D on
there as well she's one of my she's in
top five she's not quite three she's
she's
okay and then so no but I'm not really a
porn guy though you know how did that
never happen to you I just not really
thing is I know I guess I grew up in a
family where it wasn't like the more
feminists leaning people so they just
wasn't really something I ever thought
of and I think because I'm as soon as I
discover the Internet
oh [__] me I was straight on it I can
imagine that oh yeah I mean it was the
first thing you search for as soon as
you've got title WB Wrestling and I
never get those to mix them well yeah
they pretty much were that exact one
needs to show the boobs in the wrestling
than that so I haven't I've seen some
where the women wrestle each other and
stuff but then they're not as hot as we
took a breath did you notice that but
because they're not as hot as like
proper porn stars are they alone they're
all porn stars yes the ones I've seen
when I was good what so I in porn this
is one thing that did sort of happen is
because if you haven't seen like Larry
Flynt versus the people like Ponte a
really cool history of like
entrepreneurs who are fighting the
government and all of that and it but
it's some point when the internet came
in it felt like the money in the
industry seemed to take a crash
do you have a euro like conversation
about that amongst porn stars that the
good old days how was it viewed the
internet was kind of like already going
on but I've heard that from people that
like it you know girls used to be paid
better the per scene rate used to be
better but I I can't speak from
experience cuz I wasn't in the industry
at that time but I personally think that
the industry is just involving and some
people don't want to evolve with it you
know now girls are in so much more
control of their brand and so much more
control of how they want to make their
money there's so many different avenues
now where that's why I started shooting
for myself is because I got tired of
just taking a check I mean we don't get
residuals mm-hmm there's no sag in porn
you know you get a check and that's it
money yeah off your scenes forever and
like I'm not saying that you know
browsers reality kings digital or bad
our great I love them they gave me the
opportunity for so many different things
but that being said I love being my own
brand and shooting my own scenes and
making money on my website and having a
constant stream of income I'm in control
of yeah yeah you know doing scenes that
I want to do I actually feel very
similar about YouTube that's the winning
cuz you choose the same but yeah I've
just got my clothes alright similar yeah
yeah I mean you could take your clothes
off I probably wouldn't end well but I
mean we've got some weird people who
watch us maybe some of them would like
that yeah like a small minority but a
high-paying small I do that that's on
the back burner for us well yeah if my
podcast goes downhill or just inevitably
I mean come boy yeah you good yeah why
not
have you I'm still sort of curious so
I'm not too probably one off for money I
just want to put that out there right
now I would do that you know do it right
now I mean I mean lots I'd pay for this
yeah sure I love how the only thing was
that there were other men in the room
that would stop right of course mostly
men watching you yeah I definitely would
I mean let's be honest I'm not I'm the
bear on that's the thing that men on the
gay world go for in it big in the gay
world welcome to being on the gay world
have you have you ever done anything
with men where they were touching each
other no you seem a bit disappointed
when you answer that yeah I just I
didn't really get cast for stuff like
that have you ever done anything with a
man's ball I mean I'm sure at some point
I did something with someone's but I
don't really remember it's like a blur
to dudes at once but they weren't
touching oh I did you um I love Spanish
men do you see this flashposse Spanish
raw Spain
that's weird can I just say cuz yes
management no because there's two male
point Ramon and Tony rebus and I did a
boy boy girl with them
and I you would always do this thing and
it would piss off my male talents but I
just love doing it
I like whenever I do like a double blow
job I'd be like now kiss and I like make
their penises touch and like light
playing with my little pony awesome yeah
yeah anyway just just to be an [__]
like just purely because I'm a total
time under I avoid them I'm like but if
you put them both in a girl's butt it's
that's a whole other conversation so I
didn't with Tony and Ramon once and I
was like Boop and they both literally
went you know yeah yeah they didn't care
I was like I love them ya know porn
stars are the [__] best I don't get
white and bright I don't care they're
like yeah whatever Spanish - Rafa
Benitez to be proud of football up with
you don't go down by ya don't think of
it so so but there are a lot of men
obviously also on set so there is kind
of like dude and people always talk
about getting camera shy those sort of
things yeah I mean gang bangs are always
really awkward I'm like I always Hearst
I never did one but I was hear stories
like there's one guy that can't get hard
there's always one guy jerking off in
the corner you know one guys getting
more attention it's kind of yeah what's
the most amount of men - yeah it was
that Charlie - holes that are usable so
anything more than that I can't really
do anything seems a challenge not
because I've seen some women I've
struggled I kind of felt like a pig in a
luau the entire time honestly
they love them we've got some real way
with words
III didn't know it's fun but I prefer
like one partner or a three-way because
- or a three-way with a man and a woman
because two men you're just you're just
like it's a thing yeah it's just you're
just trying to get one person attention
then when you're you know the other guys
not getting attentions then you have to
go over here then you're like I just
[__] me from behind and then you're just
a pig and a luau this is the only way to
make everyone cry technology I seen one
the other day with two
a girl in a boxing gym with two guys and
by the end I was like how'd you get it
what do you search to find that Brian
come on swing gym boxing gym maybe's my
other Google search yeah I've just got
boxing Li yeah but no it was really a
challenge athletic like upside down
sometimes you're like bouncing on one
like you have to like me everybody has
to be coordinated it's like this weird
sex dance that you do because you're
balancing on one but then you're like
have to stroke I don't have mod be doing
this on you too but this is your open
with the other hand you know so it's
YouTube have got pickup problems in us
to be honest with you pedophiles are
safe all of a sudden we're like YouTube
like YouTube kids we're good so top of
trending so do you ever think of the end
user do you know what I mean or does
that sort of what does that mean I don't
know the guy watching the guy watching
cuz I can't sort I can you see them oh
yeah sometimes your eyes so that are you
just cool with that doesn't bother you I
love what you guys do cos I it's so
interesting to me really yeah because
everyone's different
do you not obviously you have your own
every one every human has their own
personal preference yeah some of these
guys are going to be not putting that
[__] disgusting so hey I'm just
saying story and tell me if this is to
your own channel raunchy I can get like
you we want you to go as far as you feel
comfortable with it's like being
directed story on my show that I was on
cam soda and I had a guide it's called
cam to cam so they can click and you can
see them and he wanted to be dominated
and like I don't dominate my scenes but
if I could tell a guy what to do like
that now it's just fun and hilarious
like it doesn't get me off but I'm a
[__] mean dog so I'm like he's in the
bathroom he's obviously like hiding from
his wife or I don't know what and I'm
like yeah jerk-off Strogatz slap your
dick
come on the wall come on your shower
wall and he just like blows this huge
load
now lick it off the guy licks it off and
like do it again and he does it a second
time and I'm like alright and that's
just like a normal day okay but do you
paint like blows my mind is he pays me
to do that
yeah and but it's in a weird way really
fun for me like I wouldn't want to [__]
a guy like that but interesting life
though is there part of it that's like
well [__] me this isn't boring it's a
lot of things but it's fine yeah yeah
like I don't want to [__] him but I'm
having so much fun dorming him and
that's why I think sex is so great like
that's why I love camming because I'm
doing you know I get to do that with
those people and like it's just fun one
thing I did find interesting was like
the replies to your replies to him oh
then everyone thought I was gonna [__]
you today no no every woman on the
podcast we get comments like that like
professionals you're gonna [__] him
you're gonna and you got no love no one
thought I was [__] you yeah our
reputations are very different I don't
know if you've picked up but we're
different people people think of us in
different ways so anyway that sort of
works yeah it's the dynamic so you said
can't wait and then immediately below
that someone called a phase and boss
doesn't look like a boss said whoa nice
and me GuestHouse
you come Danny Daniels which I guess he
means do you want to come to my house so
that sort of sent me down a thought
trail which was sort of about how many
weird [__] guys off you sell many
[__] or there's so many and how like I
wasn't I could give you look at him I'm
not yeah just grab city cleared is a man
is a man wearing a cap in front of what
looks like a religious building okay so
very religious man yeah I have
do you not I mean I would say probably
like 80% of my fans are just cooler [__]
I actually have a lot of female fans
which is awesome and I have a lot of
couple fans that's awesome
and then 20% are just weird-ass dudes
that say we're - I'm like why why do you
think they sort of get off on it some of
them Oh some of them like think you're
gonna go yeah cool whatever that I think
a lot of them want a reaction right and
I don't respond stuff like that on
social media and I think that makes them
want to do it more like what's you know
they want me to respond you know you're
just a dumb [__] it sucks dick alright I
wake up every morning and I put a dick
in my mouth all day long and then I go
to bed like that's what they think like
I'm sure you'll get comments she doesn't
know anything she's just a dumb [__]
that's you know I'm like okay moving and
then you'll get somebody cool like I
love your work you get me and my wife
off everyday thank you I'm not gonna
speak about things that I don't know
well enough to speak about but I can say
I was actually just talking to my
husband about this it was Japan uh
Denmark what was the other one Czech
Republic um they at some point had
outlawed porn right and then brought it
back and the amount of sexual abuse
dropped hmm
why is porn so bad what about it is bad
you're why can't you enjoy watching it
what about as long as it is two
consenting adults in a safe environment
what about porn is so I think it's just
miserable constant powers and I'm asking
you now do you seriously want an answer
to that I want to go I'm actually
interested I'm personally interested in
the other argument of what people say it
is because they're I think they're wrong
general I mean God if I didn't have porn
in my teenagers Jesus Christ
he'd have been beaten women I would not
were just being prima non everything if
she liked it yeah yeah I would have been
creaming on every wall but I would have
it off afterwards right can I just
I guess my part of it for me is like I
understand there's a load of consenting
adults there's a lot of people who are
mature people are there and I understand
there's like either end of that spectrum
or like the graph there are going to be
extremes where maybe pong could have
been
at some point or if someone's not had a
healthy sexual relationship someone
maybe encourages unhealthy sexual
relationship sometimes but then there
are their good and bad sides to
everything are you talking about in the
sense of like a couple couple watching
it I'm but I guess some for some people
they would get off on elements of porn
or they go down a rabbit hole
well there's a quote there's quite
brutal porn I guess is what you mean
like a BDSM when they take it to a real
far yeah which reads but but that but
the problem with that is communication
partner that's a problem porn if I enjoy
rough sex but I also know that I need to
communicate with my partner about what
is rough what it what is too rough what
is a safe word how to handle it safely
what I like what I don't like that's the
issue and I understand I am the on one
side but I feel like a lot of people
don't communicate and they see a point
they like and they don't understand that
you have to talk to your partner about
what is gonna happen you can't just then
I like to smack girls across the face so
I'm just gonna start smacking [__]
like it doesn't work like that you have
to say are you okay do you like do you
enjoy getting smacked in the face me yes
but I like it to this degree our safe
word is [__] I don't know
hippopotamus
I do think men what porn I think I'm
gonna try that and no surely women do
the same no yeah but men are watch an
anal scene for example where a woman has
been well prepared before the scene on
scene started and just think just shove
it right it's fine she's prepared I
don't have to ask her cuz all girls love
anal like no you need to communicate
with your partner and both sides join us
not I mean I'm not trying I'm not
necessarily I'm actually disagreeing
with you but then if you go to a
pornography website there is no there's
no precursor that goes remember be
consensual with your partner when you're
blah blah blah so it's sort of like a
very one-sided education is a great idea
of rapport is having something like that
before hands like jackass that's the
thing here like do don't try this at
home
yeah this was a global yeah but it's
like yeah because there's a lot of girls
who aren't when I've met them they're
like yeah we cannot do you know like
after all and I was like well well I'm
not even that first on it but but why
you know
why because there's one guy just shoved
it right one bad story and I'm all as I
quite literally you know soon my who are
these guys going around [__] again to be
clear by some Lou but to be clear then
surely that is part of Ponte so
pornography has its pluses and minuses
and one of them is that maybe it's
because so for instance I have a cousin
who did a PhD and the title was roughly
along the lines of what is good sex and
so he had a lot of chats with anyone
ranging from teenage years up to you
know guys who were 40s or whatever and a
lot of the younger people were talking
about the impact of pornography on their
sex and like how a lot of the girls
where do they get their techniques when
were all these kind of things and they
were talking about how they learned it
from porn industry but also how guys had
changed their expectations because of
that and it seemed a lot like the women
were much more able to balance their
expectations than some of the men who
were more on the side of like they say
like I guess if it's anal then just put
it in or whatever and so you're giving
me so many who thought yeah yeah good
but there's like a what do you mean good
I mean I just thought your knowing you
were dating right sorry the group you
don't even like outside of pawn so you
go from pawn remaining under and then
you meet a normal guy pawn guys are
obviously gonna be built that's it and
then you go to a normal guy and he's
probably normal but you've been going
with guys who are packing and none of
the sudden you've got a regular although
we're professionals you know like do not
try this at home you know like don't go
home with the woman and just jam your
[__] [__] in her ass cuz it's never
gonna end up in a good situation what
we're gonna end well I was minding the
photo like your your expectations of a
normal guy because he's just he and
gonna be like a stallion like what these
guys are was that a bit of her was that
a bit of a drop off for you I didn't
really date while I was in the outside I
didn't really so I can't really mmm once
why would I once you're in it you're
like oh this is late I was just getting
good dick everyday like why would I go
looking for more dick I would just do it
on camera
getting dinner no my husband is not how
do you can ask because I mean I kinda
want to do another podcast someone with
more fee you thought but how did you how
did you meet him he's laughing right now
the button ah I'll tell you okay I
wanted to I want to finish your comment
and then I'll tell you so I will say you
are right I do think there should be
something like that I think some of my
best scenes are with kink and I think
part of the reason is you fill out like
a 5 page questionnaire before you're
seen what are you into what is a hard no
what is I don't know if you know a kink
is like a BDSM site right so what is ok
for torture what is too much torture on
a scale of 1 to 10 rate all of these
implements what implements are on your
note it's it's [__] you're right like
a doctor's office like it's like
everything from a flogger to a cattle
prod you know from water torture
electricity everything they do
everything their depth by far the most
extreme site Oh God yeah what was the
furthest thing you felt that you pushed
yourself to with that I was hung from a
ceiling completely upside down with a
sybian tied in my [__] and a simians
like a good 30 40 pounds
do you notice if you miss yeah I've seen
in Houston so so but I feel like I kind
of wish the whole industry did that
because you go into that scene knowing
everything about your scene partner and
the scene is so much better so much
safer just it's I think you know you
shouldn't I wouldn't say like go home
with your partner make them fill out a
questionnaire but definitely discuss
with them what they enjoy what they
don't enjoy what's an absolute no and
you're just gonna get better sex out of
it I guess the problem is partly without
something to embarrass all that some
people maybe get like human dynamics are
not always that kind of like fill out
this questionnaire and then I'll know
everything is a kind of foreplay and be
wouldn't you want your partner to be
enjoying sex as much as you are i I
think some people would but then some
people almost don't have that emotional
capacity to think in that way I think
that's part of the problem is the
it's emotional capacity I think it's a
fundamental task like say if you're
having a drink of and just sort of
casually also what is it you know and
then you you brought it and then yeah
diamond world update do you know what
positions do you like yeah you know how
do you like your blow jobs you know are
you a full dick stroker just the tip you
know just the tip just the tip you you
know when you do these conventions
sorry dude this is my pocket we've done
summer in the city sorry we've done
summer in the city which is like a
meet-and-greet for youtubers and you
know people got very handsy with oh the
women women are worse than men for yeah
when they hug you some way they really
got a good hook yeah women think that
because I am a woman they can just grab
whatever they want not every night all
the time but some women and I'm like and
I identify as bisexual like I don't want
a woman to just [__] grab my tits or
ass without asking like that is as in
you know is it's as if a man was doing
it for me mm-hmm but yeah men what was
the weirdest thing you can remember
happen in it one of those
meet-and-greets I might have broken a
guy's nose Wow
okay let's do that summer in the city
why I I meet and greets like we do a lot
of future dancing which is you go to a
strip club and you'll do a couple shows
and then afterwards you'll do like a
meet and greet sign do photos sign
autographs stuff whatever whatever and I
was getting the stage I was at you had
to get off the stage and walk through
the crowd to go to the your dressing
room and I was naked and I was being
escorted by security but I was I ended
up like getting too much of a space
between the first security guard and me
and this guy just runs up to me and
grabs my tip right and I'm like I didn't
and I wasn't I'd even seen him coming
cuz it was like dark and I wasn't paying
attention and so I just turn I'm just
[__] hit him in the face because I
was like
I don't know what you know Chuck it was
just natural instinct yeah and he like
toes and he ran out the club it was like
what just happens maybe you want to sell
the [__] maybe he wanted his nose
broken I don't know don't do that when
you meet people don't just grab those
they're not like a person we're not even
headings ooh I guess that sort of backs
up like the whole point of everything
right Pete some people might see who's
an object also yeah they think because I
do porn they can just touch me however
they want do it I'm automatically gonna
have sex with you know that that I'm
just a sex object 24/7 you know they
don't think if I was to tell a guy don't
grab my boobs a lot of guys would answer
why I guess so you know that's part of
it because some porn stars Michael I
don't know what your core self some
point actually is Mike I don't care what
you call me okay you can call me I come
downstairs really awesome some actresses
might have a problem because they want
to keep that illusion but that is the
way that you can treat them okay with
that some girls like that I think
personally you should maybe ask them
first
do you have a name because in case you
get someone like me that's not okay with
that
Giovani element of judgment or have you
ever met people you thought you have
like issues do you know like other
actresses where you've met them are gone
you've got some issues that you need
resolve any Mike if I saw a girl with
like a drug problem yeah but like a
sexually no I have I have no reason to
judge everyone you know as long as
you're safe everyone gets off in
different ways so you know have you ever
you know you talked about that the old
days upon where like I suppose the
impression that people have it upon me
it's like drugs on set and all have you
ever been it was set and felt like it
was like the Wild West
no no I would never know and if I was I
would leave but it doesn't it's not like
that it's so corporate now it's not yeah
we had the guy in the corner we had the
guy who started you porn he was very
good we had the guy who started you
pulling on and he did say it was very
like business email it is it is because
what was funny about his story
entertainers it's a business you know
it's not you know this isn't a
Craigslist ad in some back alley yeah
yeah sure
you know we pay taxes
you know at some point I guess it was or
it was um regular yeah and there are
times where people do do bad things like
for instance
obviously there's the controversy about
spreading sexually transmitted diseases
in the industry to people not speaking
about are those sort of things as I
could genuine concern for love people it
is and you know but we get tested every
14 days and in between by the way sorry
because obviously not every so that's
the risk in the industry is because
you're working those 14 days yeah that's
why we you know we do get moratoriums
you are putting people you are at risk
at the end you know I'm not gonna stay
here and pretend that it's a hundred
percent safe because it's not it used to
be 30 days and now that you know thank
God they've made it 14 but it's that's
part of the reason why personally I
didn't want to date outside the industry
because I couldn't imagine bringing
right leading the girls risk to my
partner
right you know that's why we were both
mean I'm dating somebody in the industry
we're both in the same gene you know
sperm pool and we're both knowing you
know this is on the line and we're okay
with it but a lot of people have to
industry don't know that you know we do
get outbreaks gonorrhea does happen hmm
you know like and things like I guess
it's creepy and that sort of thing
prevalent in the United States anyway
yeah and it's not a pretty thing to talk
about but I will say it is safer than
going home with some random person and
I'm like I'm Pro condom like I think you
should wear condoms like I think you
should get tested I think you should get
tested with your partner you know be
safe because it exists we are
entertainers and we live a fantasy but
you know we we do put ourselves at risk
and there is possibility for things to
happen and they have so there was that
one time and I mean I'm sure it's
happened more times than I'm aware but I
think it was the guy called Marcus or
something like that whom he knowingly
mm-hmm kept going even though so I don't
know why it was there a reason behind
that um I want to say the story is he
photoshopped his test and exposed the
industry was it a jihad or something no
he had syphilis Oh
syphilis yeah and he expose I don't
wanna be wrong and then get attacked on
it on the Internet
but he exposed the entire industry and
so um everyone the entire the thing
about it is that there is an outbreak
the entire industry does shutdown which
is great no one's there's no shooting
allowed no one is allowed to shoot no
one you know it is and it's like one of
the few times in the industry that we
work great together as a team and we
source you know everyone that could have
been exposed everyone retests and then
it's you know the business starts back
up again but when that happened you know
a lot of people couldn't pay their bills
didn't have a savings account you know
not everyone has good money management
in the industry you know he put a lot of
people's health and lives at risk
families at risk you know and now
actually thankfully we have an online
pass system because it used to be when I
first on the industry you just like
print out your tests like a note from
your parents and be like my doctor says
I don't have AIDS where's the dip this
isn't true and then when that happened
they're like whoa Photoshop exists this
is something really scary so now we have
a pass system in directors and producers
go online and check and make sure you're
clear and then you can suck dick as
usual but I would do that in the first
place people are good people because
some people are [__] rotten human
beings and they're selfish and they
don't think about their impact on other
people's lives yeah
they don't think about that they
thinking about they want to go make some
cash they're not thinking that you know
people have families you know there's
people in the industry with children
there's people you know you can severely
ruin someone's life for your own
personal gain that's ugly
you can treat syphilis that's ours yeah
but you're still you know it's a
six-month process is it okay it's still
you know can you you can't work for six
months
Oh after testing poster for anything
after every you test was it for syphilis
it takes six I'm pretty sure don't quote
me on this but it takes six months to go
back into the clear to be able to work
again for it to completely lead or leave
your body right um uh but you know a lot
of this sauce yeah six months without
working yeah not many people
get away with you now let me do a little
running or behind the camera stuff maybe
you're right but it's a dip [__] move
so one guy can get one check now I can't
work for six months is there a is there
a thing called a fluffer is that a real
thing because one of my mates told me
about this um no what am I told you boy
I heard a story that there used to be
somebody on set like instead of doing
like a cat gee when a casting couches
but they would if in like the olden news
like the 70s if you had a new girl they
would I don't know this is sure not but
they said they would bring her to set
and if a guy who was struggling to get
hard they what she would audition so
below him get him hard Niblick oh she's
got a great mouth for TV and then she
would get work from that it's kind of
like a like a meet-and-greet for your
[__] you know so but no it doesn't
fit could we get a totally nebulous
thing I'll just I don't know it just
seems not work
yeah yes its culture right or left hand
yeah usual man yeah frozen can you get
me my phone thank God
Robin we're supposed to shooting you
okay okay Jeff directors you enjoy
working with more or less or like I
actually was a director I directed for
brazzers and reality kings and i really
enjoy it I love Holly I'm gonna say
Holly granel because she's one of my
best friends and I love shooting for her
Holly Randell okay she's a fantastic
photographer and she's just she's
awesome
Mason shot my first boy-girl movie and
my first girl-girl movie she's great I
like I don't know I guess I like the
ladies one thing I was sort of curious
of was like so obviously we've
researched you a little bit before you
come on the podcast you are also an
artist mm-hmm so other ever moments
where you think god I wish I was just an
artist or is this like there's no sort
of there's no I'm not ask if you very
good artists as well yeah look at it was
really nice it's really good art no I
don't work I I love doing a bunch of
different things I like staying busy and
I'm a little bit of a workaholic so I
like its balance art sex yeah you do
boxes you have a fashion my coffee
what's in the boxes what's in the box no
they released a mold of your [__] yeah
I've seen you getting the Maltin on
YouTube
never someone clicked so fast on there I
actually won an award for that because I
refuse to have my [__] moulded without
a bush and Doc Johnson figured out a way
to incorporate my bush and like might
shape of my bush into my toy mm-hmm he's
like he didn't know I wasn't gonna say
so yeah you've got all sorts of things
going on but you said early early on
that it wasn't work you did this because
you've enjoyed it at some point did it
start to become like this is my job and
this is what I do and can you remember
what at what point that was where you're
like I'm alright I'm a porn star now
this is what I do it's my work when I
got into it it was for fun when I
started doing guys I would say I'm like
okay I guess I'm one kind of a career
path you know like everyone kind of
thinks that you have to do girl girl
then do boy girl they
you know they think that vicious order I
think as long as you're enjoying
yourself you should just do whatever you
enjoy but then I got to a point where I
was like I'm kind of tired of playing
the same six roles all the time and
playing someone I wouldn't say something
I'm not but like I'm not a real estate
agent you know you - some of it is I am
a naughty housewife but I'm not a soccer
coach you know like so I kind of wanted
to start being more me and that's why I
kind of started streaming from my own
sites and for myself but and then I just
I just got into things like I was like I
like coffee I wanted to do my own coffee
I like silly shirts I'm gonna do my own
you know fashion line and it's just I'm
just kind of doing what I like I know
and then people like it so I'm like
that's cool
like thanks for watching me what's
special about your coffee was easy I do
it myself I work with currency coffee in
New York and I do my own blends so I
have a few different ones I love coffee
so we would love to try some I'll send
you some genuinely yeah there's first
sponsor Oreos and like my coffee Oreos
in coffee doesn't love a latte like I do
like what yeah I'm not sure you're a
coffee connoisseur though cuz the other
day we had this conversation where I
bought you a coffee about that size and
you went I like the ones from Kosta and
I why and he said more coffee
[__] how did you meet your husband
then we met at a baby shower a baby
shower
that's so innocently romantic he's
walking up today like okay we actually
received both seeing other people at the
time oh wow will you make a nicety too
though it was his baby shower we were
friends for a year we just ate we're
just friends
like there was nothing between us and we
stayed friends for years and then I
ended up he lives in New York I ended up
moving to New York for my art work and
to kind of pursue more that and shoot
for myself everything we're talking
about and then he was like my only New
York friends so we would hang out
and he has a production company or not
production sorry he has a PR company and
so he would help me with my art PR and
we were just hanging out all the time
came really good friends and then we had
that like moments and we were both
single like oh yeah makes sense sort of
thing okay so everyone's gonna be
thinking when you've got a husband and
you're a porn star like how the hell
does that work obviously like you he
needs to be extremely chill also yeah
you need to be comfortable as well how
did you well you never met my husband he
really does not give a [__] right well I
got very comfortable in his own skin
he's a very confident man and he can
handle it but he's just he does he he
knew everything we knew everything about
each other I think that's why we worked
is for two years we were like best
friends he knew everything he knew about
my exes the awful breakups I had I knew
about his breakups like and so when we
came into the relationship it was like
all the cards were on the table there
was nearly nothing to hide so he knows
he knows everything about me I need he
accepts me and he doesn't Karen he
doesn't try and change me he doesn't try
and tell me I can't do something he's
like yeah do it you know do whatever you
want he's just there for support he's my
a partner that's how partners should be
I think the idea of marriage and being
upon start going together is so forever
wanted to get married that was not I
would manage much a much of many
Pancho's do yeah I don't want kids I
still don't I never wanted to get
married with him I just he's just my
soul mate and my partner and like it
just happens but yeah I know it's I got
lucky I got some good karma I don't know
I sucks enough dicks got the good karma
going I will say this um there is
something really cool about porn because
going into my marriage I feel like I had
an advantage that a lot of marriages
don't have is that I did everything I
wanted to do in a safe environment the
way I wanted to do it so literally when
I met my husband and like [__] away
my husband [__] I'm like you were the
one that
this is exactly what I'm looking for and
I don't I'm never gonna wake up and be
like I wonder what it's like to [__] two
dudes at the same time because I've done
it
i-i've seen relationships way they're
like highschool sweethearts and then you
get like 24 and all of a sudden they
break up and it's like well because they
were both wondering what it's like to go
with other people and other things as
well but a lot of that temptation just
kicked in at some point for a lot of
people for everyone like some people you
know they're together and then that's it
but some people are curious and I'm
thankful because he's older so he's
loved it I did porn I've lived it and we
earn we know we are what we want so it's
kind of a nice advantage oh you know
you're are you getting to a point where
you have a thing a porno that'll be the
end of it for me is there a time limit
on it or see how it goes as long as it's
fun yeah as long as I'm enjoying it
I'll show my butthole when I'm 50 if I
look at and people want to see it like I
don't care nina hartley still going so I
think in porn it's important that you do
it as long as you enjoy it because when
you don't enjoy it and you have to do it
I think that causes a problem that was
some of your advice you said don't get
into porn if you're and if the money
that side you do it because you love sex
yeah do you think there are other people
who get sex doubt yeah yeah I think it
could happen I think I think people have
gone in the industry I mean like oh I'm
I feel I'm good see you later Thanks and
then some people stay on longer than
others and yeah but as long as you enjoy
it just don't do it if don't do it for
the money and don't do it if you're not
enjoying yourself
because why yeah and why is it you
mentioned that you don't want to have
kids along women might be listen to them
why not what what's the reason has
nothing to do with porn it's just I just
personally personally I just I just
don't like I just don't have any desire
I don't know it has nothing to do with
it's just my own what's quite
interesting about it for me is like your
whole or a lot of your public
personality is built around porn and sex
so everyone associate everything back
with you to that they don't really see
you as like this augmented human who's
like a real person so every decision you
make people go it must be because of the
yes yeah everybody say something that
they don't agree with Oh doesn't murder
so it must in your relationship word
still in it you two are quite good at
dealing with judgment because for
instance there are a lot of iíve met a
few guys who either not married to upon
start dating upon sorrow sort of in a
relationship with a cam girl or
something like that
and there's a stereotype about them
right there's a stereotype this guy's
[__] [__] like you know he just loves
watching his wife have say you must that
must take some level of fortitude to
deal with between you yeah it's I mean I
won't be honest and say like some people
aren't okay with what I do some you know
some of my family doesn't agree with
what I do some of his family doesn't
agree with what I do some of our friends
you know but I don't care he doesn't
care if you're not okay with it that's
fine but I'm not gonna change who I am
and he's my partner and at the end the
night we go to we go to bed together
he's my best friend we are in a
partnership together he his opinion is
the only opinion I care about why would
I care about someone that I have you
know I don't I'm not married to that
person I don't sleep with that person
you know I don't spend my life with that
person I spend it with my partner and as
long as my partner's okay with me as
long as my partner agrees with me I'll
like you know was there anyone you were
surprised was upset about you doing it
yeah I mean there are some surprises but
I don't want to I know I'm not saying
album or anything yeah yeah yeah there
was a couple of was like oh all right
you know but do you want this nice I - I
do I do I cause I'm just trying I'm
interested I'm not saying that go out
and do porn and be a sex monster like I
am not trying to I'm for me I love sex
and I love porn and I love doing it it
is not for everyone but I think what is
for everyone is not living by what other
people think of you and doing whatever
you love as a person as long as you're
not hurting anybody as long as what
you're doing cuz we cool you know do
what you love
do you know what I guess from your
website you can tell that what countries
you're big in mmm India Indian fanbase I
believe that sent a series of you're
watchin we love you okay our new
overlords
my indian following and they're awesome
like cool thanks thanks guys
no he's going he's not Indian it's very
spicy today it's just about the same but
seriously if we had an HR department you
would be in serious trouble yeah it
Britain is a brain is big and obviously
the u.s. is yeah yeah yeah actually like
my us follow me I'm actually bigger like
overseas are there a lot of other any
countries which surprise you
India surprised me because these strikes
me as like quite a religious country I
like a country where it's like oh no
it's going disagrees Indians surprised
me because I'm not Indian I don't know
why I assumed that nice right yeah like
I would think that like a Japanese porn
star would be popular in Japan I don't
know like maybe I'm wrong I guess you're
like foreign-looking go maybe yeah like
sigh me like sunny is Indian yeah you
know and she's huge then that I totally
but for me I'm like okay that's cool you
know
like if I took off for that reason she
was actually gonna come on the podcast
but then she said she was Russia refused
to talk about doing porn ever is that
Mia Khalifa Mia Khalifa yeah yes people
don't want to you know some girls just
want to they don't they want to pretend
it doesn't happen didn't happen
I don't you're gonna find out things you
haven't noticed I have nothing to hide
yeah I like living that way because it's
so much more freeing just to be like
yeah take it or leave it
someone someone to hit in about there
was a guy called James Dean who had I
think he was done for they said of rape
oh oh yeah there was like some issue in
the industry where girls came forward
and now he's coming he's coming back
into the industry a part of me and
they're saying
should that be allowed but
but I mean I don't know I wasn't there I
wasn't you know I've worked with James
he's never done anything to me that I
didn't consent to so I can't comment I
also wasn't there so I don't know you
know it's I don't want to pick a side
because I wasn't seeing it happening
part of they're making a documentary
about it but I don't know if it's gonna
be like all Kelly type [__] I just stay
in my own lane dick in my mouth see you
later thanks [__] in my mouth see you
later thanks going home but ya know all
right let me check make sure we haven't
missed any of the questions out there
are a lot of Twitter question yeah we
did get a lot more than usual okay were
they like can I have or not have ever
been days where you just like [__] I
can't do this today like performing yeah
Thursday's we're like I may be my scene
partner I'm like oh you gotta power
through oh you like a bit it's gonna be
I'm gonna have to really try here I'm
all about attitude this one has a bad
attitude like I'm instantly it irritated
so if someone like if a girl had a bad
attitude of like okay I'm just gonna
hate [__] you today Mason you're gonna
love it
we hate podcast each of us they're on
camera sometimes a little too clear
we've actually been really good recently
yeah yeah really enjoying each other's
company what what inspires your art was
the inspiration for that I wanted to I
liked doing portraits and I wanted to
highlight what the person of the
portrait was known for so for those
people that don't know I do pointillism
which is little dots that make something
else but instead of dots I do letters
and I do lyrics so for example we're
talking about prints I'm working on a
prints
where
his lyrics if when you go up close you
can read them and when you step away
it's his face how long does that take
you to do something like that one time
does it seem I mean that'll be a [__]
bonus I did um
Mick Jagger and it's about eight feet
tall and it took me like a month and a
half
you've just been photographed by um
who's that guy Nick rock that's it what
was that like oh yeah he he's like the
man that shot the 70s Oh shot you know
the iconic Queen photo most the Bowie
photos he did all the MU was like pretty
surreal for me because I kind of
fangirled and geeked out a little bit
what was it like to be photographed by
something like that
surprisingly easy he makes you feel so
comfortable and heeda has this weird way
of shooting where he'll like bark at you
or scream at you or like tell you a
story till I get emotion and it's I was
really nervous but as soon as he started
it was so comfortable mmm we met many
like famous people now because of the
job you do yeah what's not how do they
react to you and some are really cool
summer mix some I don't like meeting
people that I look up to because I get
nervous
this must be beauty trick you know
because the thing is like what if
they're an [__] yeah you know and
then yes cuz in America though athletes
are not yet like whenever they slide the
Dames of a porn site it's always [__]
oh so many athletes have you heard that
yeah yes yeah I'm I'm not gonna name any
names for this so oh my god it's so it's
so funny to me when even obviously
before I got married that guys think hey
because I'm a porn star which I
understand but you think because you DM
me and because you do something and
you're good at it that I'm going to [__]
you that makes me not want to [__] you
I'm sure it works all the time it does
to be sure but for me like I'm a brad
like now I'm not [__] you know do you
do you because I see you're doing the PR
the public relations side of things you
have access to that have you ever have
you ever received one and gone he likes
you well done
the ball always defensive and
I show him oh my god all the dick
because I get I show him it's like the
best look at this one he's like oh my
god what is this
yeah why are you showing me this oh
they're any good kicks though I'm sure
if it was shot by a Mack truck then it
would be a fantastic one do you not I
mean
this is my Bowie dick pic that'll be
amazing what's a good this is a good
dick pic possible have you ever had a
good one what's the name industry but I
frame them up not sending a dick pic
this is it you're telling me you've
never sent a dick pic when it asked for
that's right I wanna see how far into
this I need to go yes right yeah because
this point were you doing it probably
hit a guy before you got married were
you a bit like I'm used to oh yeah yeah
I need some prime cut meat here so let's
see what you got going on don't waste
your time you want the marbling a steak
steak yeah so just out of just message
to everyone at home dick pics suck I
like foreplay
that is not foreplay that is all the
play like I don't need to have sex with
you now because I've seen it and I'm
pretty sure how you're gonna [__] with
it yeah you know and a lot of people
sort of blame or put porn in the same
part of that culture do you know what I
mean like men expecting things straight
away because boys what could be I guess
quite an instantly rewarding thing yeah
I think a lot of people watch porn and a
apply it to their sex life yeah I and B
think whatever it's like television
whatever they see on TV is real whatever
girls do on camera all girls do and all
girls are into you know I don't like
getting [__] blasted in the face with
a come shot that is horrible
it is not my own emotion there are some
girls that like it there's some girls
that like it but I don't you know it's
just everyone's different but I think
men and women of just different
generally as well so like with a man
when we look at a woman
I love those boobs getting is turned on
getting as excited maybe if I show what
I've got
she'll get excited doesn't doesn't work
no you have to have a conversation we're
emotional that's right I mean maybe some
girls like dick thanks but I feel like
most women are emotional we want to
connect whereas men want once we started
I turned on is animalistic in it it's
like like I'm pretty sure like there's
animals out there that present
themselves but men we want to do that
you look at this they're doing a dance
what why is it certain about the win
minute that will impress huh German I
should probably be impressed by the yeah
tie it in a bow and then send it to me
and I'll be impressed
we've all read the song yeah yeah I mean
so that I guess it's all sort of tied
together though isn't it like that kind
of instant reward like those like tinder
and those kind of things what's your
opinion
everything's so instant now instead this
instant that you know Instagram do you
think internet dating was like healthy
because it's definitely changed the way
everything's so fast yeah this is it no
one's enjoying anything and I'm gay I'm
guilty of it you know you sit down and
your your food looks good so you take a
picture and you post on Instagram you're
not enjoying it you know you go
somewhere you know you're taking a
picture you're documenting you're not
enjoying the moment
it's just everyone so it's so important
for everyone to care about what people
think of them on the internet but that's
all they're caring about you're not
enjoying it you're gonna wake up and
you're 50 and you haven't remembered
anything you've done cuz you were too
busy posting it online
I try and avoid that like cuz I feel
like I spend so much time on camera that
when I'm not on camera I don't want to
[__] yeah do the whole Instagram
story I'm guilty of it and I think it's
important because you know your fans
want to see that I kind of have to do it
though isn't it a little bit yeah but
there's moments where I'm like what did
I just eat I was so busy talking I mean
so you I'm sorry I don't know what your
husband's call was Vic sorry what were
you a bit reluctant to post things with
Victor
initially the first two months after
think I engage brain I read the story
where you said about the hole where you
said we didn't announce the engagement
for two months so you were reluctant
lend it so I yeah I like to it was like
he was just it was weird for me with him
because I knew he didn't care he was
like tell anyone I don't care you know
it's you can post me I don't care but I
was so afraid and I cared about him so
much that I didn't want to unleash the
Internet hate on him but naturally there
would have been some of that initially
he was like yeah people are jealous you
know he's older people commented suit
you're dead you know it doesn't matter
what he look like though dude he must
have money cuz he's older than you it's
just like it's irrelevant that he's a
multi-millionaire billion yes sorry yeah
uh my favorite thing that he says though
when people say that he goes nope must
be the other thing got a great place now
that's but I didn't I I like a guy was
in this like weird head space cuz like
what do i do you know even though he was
fine with him like do I want to do that
to him and then I was afraid like is he
gonna leave me because of that and then
I'm like you know why if he leaves me
because of that I wanna be with him
anyway it's but I when we got engaged I
waited because I was like should I she's
scary
you know yeah I like to my fans even
want to see this do they want to do they
want to forever think that I'm you know
a single living my whole life [__]
everybody you know or do they want to
see the real me and I was you know what
[__] it I'm just gonna show the real me
I'd spend my entire career up to this
point telling him everything I might as
well continue it and the response was
great you know you always get hate mail
but a lot of people are into it he he
we're at ABN and someone asked him first
signature he's like why yeah [__]
goodnight
yes I and now instead of being the the
single hell on the naughty housewife so
it's just a rebrand I mean let's be
honest it doesn't matter what the
situation is men want a good loving
woman so I'm glad I'm glad I'm open
about it because I sleep better at night
I'm not hiding anything yeah I thought
would probably wind you a bit
considering how like out there you are
judging having that one thing be a
secret is view yeah what we've got the
something on Wikipedia one last you Bo
are curious information because I
related to that was the first question I
was like are you our little sister you
have the same fake last name what's
Donald Trump like scum on Wikipedia scam
artist one man failed to complain
against usually in claiming that you'd
scammed him out of money but then you
failed a countersuit saying that he just
wanted to force the case in order to get
contact with you in some way yeah what
was that likely go through I get so many
emoji far away I get so many people that
get to scam they use my photos and I'm
the perfect candidate for photos to use
to scam people because I don't look like
a porn star
I'm not blonde I don't have fake tits
and there's so many like that's like the
stereotypical look you know I look like
I could be just the girl next door
exactly um but there's also a plethora
of nude photos of me online so these
people go they take all my photos and
you can actually pretend to have a
relationship with someone because now
you have nudes of me that you can send
to somebody they're thinking they're in
an actual relationship because where
else would you get naked photos of you
know and then I get this hate mail I get
hate mail my husband gets death threats
just it's you know you I sent you $300
in iTunes cards you [__] [__] I'm
like
first of all first of all I'm personal
you dumb Punk
why would I ask for an iTunes card
mm-hmm you know don't send people money
you know if you want to support me
support my TV show support my fashions
for the things I'm selling you know buy
my porn why would I ask people from like
why but I've seen even on the tweets
someone replied something yesterday and
even then you were correcting someone
the guy was like oh I've spoken to you
before and you're like no I mean I
actually tried to do that as much as
possible because I don't want people to
think that I mean I'm not in a
relationship with anyone I am NOT
leaving my husband I don't have a sister
that lives in Ghana you know my dad's
not dead and I need money for the
funeral
like whatever else I actually had
somebody show up to a bar that I was
doing a meet-and-greet at and hold up
their phone and be like who is this
Danny
who is this and I'm like that's me in my
living room taking a selfie this is your
sister she needs help
I'm like dude that is my living room
that is a photo of me it's your twin
sister and the guy next to him at the
way I was like no no and they don't you
know once your tricks you can't there's
no way you don't want to be I can say
that they want because they know the
message whoever it is and they'll say oh
no I just had to say that because I was
in public
oh no she's lying you know whatever
[__] excuse it's crazy it's crazy
obsessed sex definitely muddies the
waters I had a guy take me to court
because he thought that I had scammed
him for iTunes card mine just for the
gone and Guardian relative yeah I don't
I don't we didn't it didn't go enough
far enough to know what the details were
but um I countersued did you - yeah I
had to go to court and meet him can I
just surreal that would be for him as
well jeez
oh he didn't really he realized pretty
quick oh really what was it alone I
think you I I don't know if it was him
wanting to meet me or him wanting to
date and he already he really thought I
was I don't know what was going through
his head I didn't talk to the guy you
know but he I showed up with my lawyer
and then I countersuit it was like this
isn't
not happening I am NOT gonna open the
floodgates for people to come after me
when I've done nothing wrong because
someone stole my photos [__] you that's
actually quite sad for here you lost
your money because you're [__] dumb
and you didn't do your research and you
[__] send someone money that you've
never met that is your problem
but for quite a while you can imagine he
thought he was dating you so then when
he then gets into court or whatever
would you're mine yeah mine [__] that
is like the catfish where it's like yeah
it would CIA now that place is not a
thing go maybe I should stop sign and
Alexis tell Texas all of those cards
probably although Apple sincerely thanks
you for still gives IQs cards I want to
[__] lose that like you need an
iTunes Court yeah that's like your
grandma gives you those at Christmas you
know it's like it's like it's like the
new scam as opposed to you I don't know
if it was here but there was one in the
u.s. everything you won the lotto send
good-faith money and then we'll send you
your you know you're married you're
related to some Prince's okay you can I
think it they do iTunes cause you can
get the money off and then you can get
like refunded or something like that I
mean maybe that's the scam yeah really
small yeah that's what porn sort of
surrounded by as well though isn't it
like loads of scammers because obviously
it's a really easy way to I will never
ask my fans for money ever ever and
that's where product unless right yeah
unless there's a support I'm doing this
support I would never just like can I
have $300 like what
ouch she is that also imagine if like
this you're so like your favorite porn
star came to mine I'm gonna need $300
because would you cuz the hotel you're
staying it doesn't seem very nice I
would have said yeah she's not the
[__] know yeah
yeah it's a nice saucer allele yeah
should be long gone by the time you see
this it was so I once knew an old guy
who gave me advice when I was a kid not
a kid but like it you know teenagers I
saw how you wash it give it to you yeah
that's not what he said but he did say
like an upstanding penis knows no mercy
and now I almost spit my water that is
amazing yeah now I take I I took that
quote to mean a couple of things so
first of all like if a guy is sexually
aroused then that was the real core I
thought you were [__] joke what's
this hero is a family person fully
clothed I'd like to start saying before
I have sex like I would [__] run away
yeah I heard one that was God gave men
two heads and only enough blood to run
both oh one road there was also this
basil yeah so there's the other quote
that if a man can control their sexual
urges then they are that's man is true
English I have thought in my head
sometimes that this is a drastic thing
the thing pot with my life be if I
didn't have sexual urges like I get so
much more done I'd be amazed us but then
I'd probably be more productive generous
but then would I be as motivated because
one of my motivating factors is
impressing women do I mean so like that
needs a big part of it like the money
the status and I think that's partly why
I like the big sports stars in the big
music stars go I've done it now like you
should where's the women they get that
point that's true it's a really good
point it's like when you have a million
subscribers on YouTube sighs where's the
women
will that will Vernon we all know but a
viral I do not I don't know what I was
thinking but you do get me I've seen ego
in young men and that's kind of where it
goes well the reason I said that was
because like so basically need you're
blinded by your penis a lot of the time
and so a lot later by your grace was a
better song but we could we could rework
you need to cover so like some kind of
blind about that so there will be a lot
of men out there who like seen pictures
of you and think that is that person
then oh my god I'm in love with this
woman like I really want to give her
money like there's there's people that
that get scammed knowing a fake me and
then realize they're scams and then
think the real me is the same as this
scam yeah does that make any sense me
there's a new financial thing with where
men get off on being financially like
humiliated by women they somewhat better
know but what would you say to a guy
like you once that because I don't know
no financial domination is really
interesting to me but yeah I'm not look
like I said like as long as your fetish
is legal and safe like I don't care what
it is
everyone's you know enjoy it give me
though you want to give me all your cash
[__] give it to me that's sort of on
Kim's thought I don't wanna liquor come
off a wall whatever makes you happy
and have you ever um I know didn't
really know how to follow up with that
but I wasn't saying like it was the
first fun have you ever felt bad after
doing something no I shouldn't have done
that
no not if they asked for it right um no
because they wanted it no cuz they're
consenting it's all the guy a guy gets
in the room and I'm like [__] you look
here come off the wall like if he's
asking I would like to know what what
what what you know he clicks off you are
so cause he's finished now so I'm Muslim
middle that's his problem
not five minutes of him just looking in
the mirror brushing his teeth or
whatever I don't know what he's doing
after I'm assumin brush I mean the rest
of the come off the well the spit off
the wall maybe
conditioner what's up what's that son
yeah
oh no he's still living at home he's
over 18 so I was thinking that I know
it's a weird Avenue to go down but I've
come already some people get that thing
where they go and then I think they come
on my social media and [__] message
me mean things
oh really think sometimes guys jerk off
I'm not saying this is the reason but I
think this actually happens sometimes
and then they get angry because whatever
their religious their wife they feel
guilty they come they're like you're a
[__] [__] I'm like makes them feel
better almost yeah maybe maybe yes it's
like yeah hate you yeah that's so weird
yeah do you get I mean you're from
America I guess you from a more liberal
state but like there's a lot of
religious people who don't do the
pornography oh yeah have you ever been
you've never really want to be part of
like a campaign to help one side or the
other just not my cup of tea yeah you
know you ever get confronted by people
because there are very active yeah I get
people that are like hateful and social
media and stuff and like there's people
that are like super religious to try and
get like pages taken down and you had
your Instagram taking down a few times
what was tense
really you got to she's got 2.4 million
that's an that's an insane engagement
you know I mean if you want a spot he's
gone my search the name again she must
have said another one up literally what
happens with porn stars all the time we
get deleted and then like yeah they have
to go find one I find it really you know
I said about like porn girlfriends when
they disappear and they just go off and
live their life I'm like well you know
let us normally you're gonna go chin I
mean there was one called
I think she was called now you owe me
Russell have you ever heard of her brute
brunette and all of a sudden she just
yes no some girls just like disappeared
having a kid or something what are you
doing it that must be weird what do you
know any pawn stars with kids oh yeah
yeah it softens when the kids get older
yeah
that's family industry having kids
that's why I'm like you think about like
I don't know how you doing and stuff
like you you know you busy busy dick
yeah when you come home and you've got
like kiss your son on the cheek before
he goes to well I'm assuming you're
washing your I mean we're not driving
home like doo-doo-doo whoops forgot to
clean out again I don't have kids so I
can't I don't know but a lot of people
the industry do have them they see it as
a job I mean it's a job that's nice
I don't mean like you know the sets but
I mean like to be on set like is it nice
because you want it to be like a
comfortable environment like I've worked
on some shows where they go have a
shower here and I'm not showering better
than others yeah at the point you're at
now though you're like one thing is when
I was shooting for other companies there
had to be a shower on set right because
sometimes you would like book a
warehouse cuz you're doing like a Grammy
thing and there's no shower here I'm
like what am I supposed to do in
particular that looks like he looks
really vicious a dungeon but it is the
cleanest set it's it's all paint and set
design because it like soul it's like
you could just wipe the floor and it
would be like spotless it was just made
to look that way yeah very hygienic yeah
they're very you know they're that you
can't walk like it's a huge paycheck
they recently sold a building but it was
a huge armory and you could there is
rules like you couldn't walk around just
naked you couldn't walk around barefoot
because if you cut yourself or you know
they followed all the rules so but it's
just these guys have this shift together
they are the best they really are
because if my producers well enough to
you guys the people of the outbreaks
left right and center no offense boiled
we know Brian's had that experience me
he's gone it's gone I think his wife
said no more for you she's Spanish has
any how do you she's not special folks
how do you how do you like manage your
diet around this sort of thing because
obviously you got to remain in shape
yeah but the other side of it is
burping like bean burrito in someone's
face after no I always treated every day
like a blind date you know you always
what like I would always wash my hair
shave my legs shave my butthole make
sure why the puzzles if you've got a
bush why are you shaving the butthole
because surely it's all okay um I need a
lot of like there's a lot of shaving
that happens okay I don't wake up like
yeah I saw every day but sorry so then
what 8:00 on set like what's the UM do
you have to worry about that because if
you are doing if someone's doing an anal
scene or something for example yeah and
that's really gonna be a garlic-breath
that's a whole nother conversation
because everyone you know some girls
don't even eat if they're doing an anal
seeing if you want to stay like clean
that whole thing but um yeah you're
conscious like sometimes I don't
I won't even eat before cuz you want to
be look the skinniest and yeah you know
you don't wanna be all bloated and then
those angles will be wouldn't forgiving
I guess that's thing important like I
can't weigh or something yeah so hide
the fact that I'm [__] bloated yeah
you don't post it's so you gotta make
sure I just gotta find the right
category I'm sure there's some guys are
gonna be like bloat if I can't agree for
everything I'm sure there is
I mean you can what we type any word
into a porn site and just be like yet
found it building porn yeah you know I
mean architectural porn but yeah what's
the weirdest porn you've heard of what I
think is weirdest you know yeah what do
you think's weird
is there anything you're actually kind
of fun to do but balloon popping balloon
popping it's a fetish what do you mean
just like no like sitting bouncing on it
you know squishing with your legs I've
seen women like crush watermelons and
[__] with like their gym goes wrong
Aman they are strong as [__] yeah thick
thighs save lives
I'm crush watermelons apparently yeah
you know we're learning a lot about you
yeah women crush food to be honest I
thought smashing yeah food and sex I
don't really I I always mixed up but
like the crunching like the chewing in
the micro maybe a morrow is that
becoming HD because air some are girls
on YouTube are like the hottest girls on
YouTube pretty much so it's I guess in
porn more takes a lot from whatever's
trending with real life so if something
is popular usually you're gonna be on
set you're like okay we're doing this
today like spinners like fidget spinners
yeah oh really there yeah there was a
girl that like stuck one in her ass you
know cuz it's gonna be like a trending
topic it's fun right just in case the
kids are searching for that I don't see
your SEO oh yeah like whatever if
there's usually if there's something
that happened like when Kim Kardashian
did that like shot somebody mimicked it
for a porn you know there's always they
do like parodies of a lot of popular
thing I've done a musical Moorman if you
know what nobody do parrot I actually
love the Book of Mormon right I think
Dave Thomas Browne is the best elder
price I'm just gonna throw that out
there it's a great choice what do you
what do you think do you agree yes I
actually think the Book of Mormon might
be the best musical I've ever seen yeah
yeah we're doing any covers like goes in
like you know when they do porn covers
of like real movies yeah what's the fun
is my favorite
I did kill bill and I had to wear a
blonde wig it was awful but I got do
wire stunts and the wires stuntman why
Oh what should we do with this extra
money wire stunt like let's put a bunch
of hoes on wires that have no idea what
they're doing put in my dumb ass was
like yeah and the cool thing was the
wire guys were the original stuntmen
from Power Rangers so I was like geeking
the [__] out and they were like they
would like heist me in the air and I be
like Pink Ranger yeah parodies there was
like this phase of parodies and they
were just all so bad but so fun yeah I
remember did nail and Sarah Palin oh
yeah popular warden yeah she like you
must they must have counted their
blessings oh yeah I would recreate I
would like to be Neil like so like I'm
just singing I'm Neil I'm in the jacket
and I'm giving you and then and then
more fees cause he is the one he's
beginning to believe you can't oh yes
and then the full the interesting side
that that would be the full 360 around
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I was weird
midday yeah oh so she's a voice like
there's like a million of them they like
oh yeah mister I'm not miss a game
no no mr. Anderson's the guy the name of
and then I call and then it's coming
towards efficiency avoids it yeah that
you stops the droplet yeah that's
Commissioner that's one of the most
disappointing sides let's do this that's
the way to suggest the polar when you
are here that I'm never gonna suggest
people go now comes to come shot and
she's like no in slow motion and they
just one drop the cutters are on the tit
she's like
it got me there we go should we I think
can I just say like the other side of it
is that people tend to frown on porn or
look down on it because they feel like
like they don't like the way it reflects
on us they don't like to look at the
reality of society this is what we I
sort of got from what was the you pong
guy called dude we've interviewed we've
done over a hundred now the guy did
crazy taxi with Freight fake taxi taxi
right so they're selling that taxi but
not Thomas comes someone's auctioning
the taxi off stop bidding on it the bids
run up the 60 grand he's out come on
we're not there's [__] isn't the
real cars just a [__] taxi it's not
even the real yeah
well that's partly I imagine whether
someone just wants to roll around in it
like it yeah that's your event from the
bathroom
it was quite insightful talking to him
because he was talking about how people
clicked certain parts of videos and like
you could see what people are searching
for I feel like some people don't like
it because it's like it publicly
reflects the way that people feel into
what people are getting off on but
they're closed doors I might like that
quite private because there's like
especially in England name no but I mean
I'm not saying like John Smith enjoys
gangbangs but it's you know like a broad
reflection though of society that people
are going like so many people got in
porn and it's such a big thing is such a
big industry I think some people just
don't like how it reflects on says I
don't mean that from a judgmental stand
but I mean like that worries them and
yeah but the truth yeah exactly so they
just want to face up so they maybe they
just don't want to hear the truth
whereas it seems you take the opposite
route where you're sort of like look I
accept that this is what it is and we're
just going to say it which I do find
that quite interesting I [__] you if you
hide in a bubble and you pretend that
things aren't what they are how are you
going to evolve as a culture you know oh
I don't you know no one watches milf
porn yeah that's like the number one
most searched term no one likes pissing
in holes in hotel rooms I thought I
wouldn't have a
Wow Lawrence revealing I don't know it
my first point what trust was lesbian
porn
they were like from the future
like the year 3000 yeah but like when I
say from the future
it was just like we're really bad like
CGI toys and they've got like shiny
reflective clothing on because that's
what everyone wears but yeah that was
the first point I was about was the
choice that's what you it was on TV
anyway and I was like 13 right nice Wow
like a weird definitely not but now that
I've mentioned the matrix maybe I don't
know that was the first one I think I'm
not gonna be true by Corona star wars
porn dreamy this has been a good Chuck
Darwin yeah I've enjoyed this should we
should we wrap it here and then and
maybe do another one next ask a final
question oh yeah so I like to ask
everyone one final question
well actually I'm beginning to do two so
first one if your life was a movie what
would be the turning point in the middle
of the movie for you Oh
meeting my husband lovely answer last
question and I mean that sincerely
what last question would be how would
you like to be remembered for doing what
I love and not apologizing for it yeah
well I was if I was to say that the
answer would be you just don't give a
[__] which I really which is like a more
fun way to say I prefer yeah so it's
been lovely
well brothers
can we get use ball for next time man
yeah right well we'll do it
we go